hallo herzlich willkommen zur liest
fällt deswegen gerade auf tour in den
usa
gestern war bereits bei kitsch nicht in
der produktion in greenville und heute
steche 10 chicago und zwar beide teams
gleich mit der lieben januar von
kitchenaid treffen unserer hierhin sowie
in diesem roten gebäude da ist nämlich
ganz oben drin
world of world und die liebe gerne hat
eine richtig tolle neuigkeit für mich
eine chance ist einfach
hallo hallo sally herzlich willkommen
der world of work von kitchenaid da
schon nicht mehr kennen zu lernen und
den weg gehen gemacht hat dank wie die
einfach und wir gerne dann machen wir
ein schönes frühstück vorbereitet das
heißt meister frühstücken super gerne
die liebe jana hatte uns ja das
frühstück gerichtet und haben wir
zusammen erst mal ein bisschen frühstück
ein bisschen geplaudert und dann bekamen
wir eine kleine führung durch das
gebäude
was ein richtig schönes altes gebäude
auch war mit viel geschichte auch auf
bahnsteigen genau aus backsteinen dieser
tour mit der uhr drauf war richtig schön
und das immer anders gelaufen konnten
dann auch ganz oben im turm einfach mal
so chicago anschauen also wirklich
rundherum von allen vier seiten und da
wurde uns auch so ein bisschen was der
geschichte von kitchenaid erzählt wir
haben die erste maschine gesehen und
einfach so auch den verlauf der ganzen
maschine was sich verändert hat und was
natürlich auch gleich geblieben ist über
die ganzen jahre ja die story alles
hingenommen werde es erfunden hat und
bei dieser führung er wurde uns zum
beispiel auch erzählt wie zum beispiel
auch der name kitchenaid zustande kam
am anfang gab es noch keine namen
einfach die maschine konstruiert und
dann der frau mit gegeben ich glaub vom
gründer oder vom ingenieur und sie dann
damit gearbeitet und sie haben ihr den
auftrag gegeben jetzt überlegt doch mal
einen namen für diese küchenmaschine und
setzt damit gearbeitet wochen lang und
hat dann gesagt also mir egal wie ihr
das ding nennt aber für mich ist eine
kitchenette was heißt das heißt hilfe
zustande
ja na du bist ja brand managerin bei
kitchenaid jetzt fragen sich
wahrscheinlich meine zuschauer was macht
ein brett manager überhaupt ja das ist
ganz vielseitig ich muss sagen ganz
spannender job und natürlich für eine
marke wie kitsch made auch noch ein ganz
schöner job das heißt im prinzip kümmern
wir uns darum wo sind wir mit der marke
wie präsentieren wir uns nach außen das
geht vom produkt über produkteinführung
ganz viel marktforschung ist dabei man
reist ganz vieles viele leute die man
trifft und einfach netzwerke die man da
aufbaut und pflegt und im prinzip geht
es darum wie wollen wir wahrgenommen
werden und wie welche tools brauchen wir
dafür um damit das passiert
er klingt echt zu verspannungen und
gerade jetzt in chicago eine richtig
tolle stadt sieht man natürlich auch
ganz schön viel von der welt
das stimmt also doch da unterwegs ist
man auf jeden fall
wir haben schon miteinander geschrieben
und das meer erzählt es gibt ganz
spannende neuigkeiten und meine
zuschauer nicht wir sind schon ganz
gespannt darauf hast du uns zu berichten
haben ja ich bin auch sehr gespannt
darauf und du als großer fan der
küchenmaschine wirst dich bestimmt auch
über die neue freundin sofern spanne ich
uns gar nicht länger auf die folter
erklären wohl uns mal unsere neue ihr
könnt euch mal die küche im hintergrund
angucken die sieht so toll aus richtig
schöne große amerikanische kueche große
geräte viel platz also soviel platz habe
ich zu hause nicht und setzte auch nie
haben
genial höfen zwei backöfen da hinten
noch im backofen so groß für so einen
richtig großen gehen zu braten und zwar
präsentiere ich dich hier unsere neue
kitchenaid mir lieber kleine kleinere
versionen unserer küchenmaschine wie du
siehst kannst du die größenunterschied
schon und wir sind total angetan weil es
wirklich die nachfrage danach so besteht
kleinere küchenmaschinen die küchen
werden kleiner die arbeitsflächen sind
nicht so groß
die haben wir natürlich eine große
fläche aber diese komplettes gegenteil
was ich eben gesagt welche gerade von
dieser großen küche geschwärmt ok und
das ist natürlich nicht so eine
riesengroße küche habe jetzt kommst du
damit nominell ja gut in amerika hat man
natürlich seine großen küchen aber auch
gerade hier in chicago die appartements
da sind die küchen schon kleiner und
grad in europa die durchschnittliche
küche ist er bei neun quadratmetern das
heißt wirklich begrenzten fläche und wie
gesagt die nachfrage ist groß
bei der maschine ist sieht man ja
einfach den größenunterschied und man
wie du vielleicht fühlt wenn du sie mal
an hebt sie es halt wirklich 25 prozent
leichter ok das heißt selbst wenn ich
einfach den arbeitsplatz nicht habe kann
ich sie mir schnell und einfach mal an
eine position stellen wo ich sie
vielleicht brauche und habe einfach
weniger gewicht insofern also bei mir
war es wirklich auch schon oft so dass
ich auf messe war und arbeitet auch in
meinen küchenmaschinen und dann kommen
eben auch manchmal zuschauer die dann
sagen mensch ich hätte auch so gerne
küchenmaschine
der platz in der küche reicht mir
einfach nicht aus und das war jetzt auch
der grund warum ihren gesagt habt macht
es eine kleinere genau einmal der
begrenzte oder die begrenzte
arbeitsfläche natürlich andererseits es
gibt es auch einfach super viele single
haushalte mit 60 prozent die anzahl da
schon recht groß oder auch pärchen
zusammen wohnen ohne große familien und
da ist einfach das fassungsvermögen
geringer was benötigt wird um vielleicht
nicht gerade den großen kuchentheke zu
machen sondern nur mal schnell ein paar
kekse und da haben wir hier eine
kleinere schüsse mit 33 liter
fassungsvermögen statt der 48 und das
ist natürlich dann gerade wenn man
alleine ist oder nur zu zweit die
perfekte größe wie sich herausgestellt
hat
passt ja wahrscheinlich auch besser
unter so hoch schränke in der küche
genau wenn man den motor auf sie dann
auch an hebt sieht man einfach da hört
man von höhe auf einer ganz anderen höhe
aber wie du aussiehst haben die
knethaken und flach hörer was man so von
der design küchenmaschine kennt und auch
der schneebesen sind auch bei der
maschine mit dabei das heißt auch dass
man perfekt ausgerüstet und unsere liebe
ansatz habe auf die verzichten wer auch
nicht auch hier kann man alle passt
attachments ranmachen den fleischwolf
luise schneider spielt schneider das
recht in mini ausführung sondern genau
das sind die gleichen die ganz normalen
dass dies für die maschine und die große
maschine gibt kann die können hier von
ran
einfach das ganz normale zubehör was ich
auch zu hause habe für die große
artisten gipfel also kann man auch hier
benutzen ganz genau
man hat die gleiche leistung also man
verzichtet hier auch bei der leistung
auf gar nichts und hat einfach eine
kleine vision sowie ja kennst du ja auch
apple und auch bmw haben ja auch eine
mini version herausgebracht und stimmt
wir präsentieren jetzt sanierer dass die
küchenmaschine nicht sehen
sonst sagt sie gleich mama das ist
bestimmt machen
ja das ist könnt ihr parallel ihre
rezepte herstellen
aber natürlich dafür sorgen dass sie
natürlich auch super von der größe denk
ich mal lief einfach wie handlich auch
vom insel ist und ja wir haben auch
sechs richtig tolle farben bei der
maschine liga es bringt also kannst du
richtig gespannt wenn die zeige ich dir
später einmal
und das hier ist jetzt klar wie blaze
kein ding ich könnte sich auch in deiner
küche ganz gut machen ja und so die
schwester zur himbeereis genau passen
sich farblich ganz gut an
also die sind echt total eklig aus am
liebsten würde sie gleich ausprobieren
meine zuschauer fragen sich jetzt
bestimmt auch gibt sie denn auch in
deutschland hat sich in chicago
natürlich aber gibt es die auch bei uns
haben derzeit doch nicht tatsächlich wir
sind jetzt gerade in der produktion für
europa und in deutschland wird es die
maschine ab herbst winter jetzt in
diesem jahr geben
doch dass hier tatsächlich ja aber wir
haben eine kleine überraschung für dich
oder nicht bar würden wir dir gerne eine
maschine mit nach hause gegeben dass du
die gleich zu hause ausprobieren kannst
ganz in ruhe in deiner kirche und die
kannst du dir in der unser produktion
direkt vom band rollen okay geben wir
uns selbst in die fraktion das machen
seehofer und euch nämlich natürlich mit
deinen weg ausprobieren
jetzt gleich rein in die produktion der
mini aber ich muss natürlich erst mal
sicherheitskleidung anziehen und dann
sehe ich darin wieder
nein
er führt mich jetzt so
mini produktion
deggendorf
also dieses regal die mini produziert
zwar hat man hier vorne diese
eine lang schäden auftreten
beim komfort
und das einfach alles sicher ist
von dem positiven
dessen produktion nicht mehr anfahren
wie war der großen
das sieht
jedoch kaum
funktionieren
30 meter lang
weitere personen die jetzt hier beim
zusammen
mitarbeiten
zuerst
sambo ist dass man bei der mine
jetzt drohen
oktober
der kinder
arbeiten
die arbeit auf
den vorteil dass motor richtig
auf eine bombe
menschen
for machine und weise gut
voll fort
nicht
arbeit
ganz gezielt einsetzen
fragen zusammen ist
unser von st
mit
ich darf hier diese susanne mini mit
nach hause nehmen eine erste mini in
europa das war jetzt der letzte tag in
der kita und produktion und ich hoffe
natürlich dass er genügend einblicke
bekommen habt für uns war es wirklich
super interessant alles mal zu sehen und
insgesamt waren wir ein paar tage da und
konnten wirklich viele fragen stellen
uns wurden viele antworten gegeben und
einfach ganz viel hintergrundwissen auch
zur maschine die ich einfach vorher gar
nicht hatte ich fand das interessante
war für mich war persönlich interessant
natürlich auf die maschine aber wie die
leute arbeiten genau wie sieht die
sicherheitsstandards die sicherheit
wieder in ihre mitarbeiter behandeln was
passiert ist sich immer für mich auch
welchem produkt drin was steht alles
dahinter und dass sie einfach
umwelttechnische vorgaben wie gehen sie
die umwelt um wird recycelt das alles
zum beispiel auch das wasser bei dieser
bei dieser lackieranlage dass wir nur
dann immer wieder gefüllt hat wird und
wieder verwendet wird fand ich super
interessant und sicherheit wird ganz
groß geschrieben deswegen durften
beispielsweise auch die kinder gar nicht
mit nach hinten sie waren zwar immer mit
dabei aber einem sie durften dann nach
draußen murat und andre ward eigentlich
den ganzen tag draußen mit ihnen
irgendwann spazieren seifenblasen machen
straßenkreide mal und im wald haben wir
auch immer gegessen das war schön es hat
irgendwie sowas von von camping
charakter finde ich wie gesagt das
wollte man in dem video auch zeigen
genau dieses problem ist einfach im
regal steht sowie den bug rahmen zum
beispiel erklärt habe nicht nur im regal
man sieht nur den preis man sieht immer
nur das ding holen ist dass dahinter
nicht was alles dahinter steckt und was
eigentlich den preis oder die marke
ausmacht genau
da wurde ich echt bestätigt also bisher
war wirklich alles sehr positiv und ja
im nächsten video wir haben noch ein
video warum es um unsere usa reise geht
da geht dreht sich alles nur um chicago
da haben wir laufen in chicago rom genau
da waren ein paar tage in chicago und
haben euch da einfach richtig tolle
richtig richtig tolle bilder mit
aufgenommen
das problem war natürlich auch immer
dass wir nicht immer wussten wo dürfen
wir filmen und wir hatten nicht immer
die kamera mit dabei gut auf das handy
aber wir haben sich alles mitnehmen
können das ist zunächst mal so ein
bisschen anders jahren noch mein film
ein problem ist einfach die zeit ja es
war einmal zwei bis wenn wir nicht mehr
so was machen sechs tage für usa das ist
viel zeit in die kameras auf den kopf
riesenstein verlieren sonst als in den
usa geht wirklich mal 234
wir werden auf jeden fall wiederholen
also ist auch von usa zu usa sondern
auch unterschiede geben
ganz extrem also hab ich mal gerne los
so anders sein als die südküste als die
westküste und auf jeden fall nach
amerika geht dann schaut euch alles an
ja macht der rundreise ja also wie
gesagt heute abschluss greenville und
dayton und beim nächsten mal geht es wie
gesagt nach chicago
ja also flasche was beim nächsten mal
und danke fürs einschalten bis zum
nächsten mal
das macht's gut